a police Constable is facing the sack
after being found guilty of gross
misconduct for using excessive force
when she repeatedly beat an
ex-footballer with her bat on after he
was taser to the ground an independent
tribunal found Mary Ellen Bentley Smith
acted wrongly when she hit Dalian
Atkinson three times with her battle
during an incident in August of 2016.
the ex-aston Villa player later died
join me now Sky correspondent sadio
um just brings up to date with this
Sadia
um so this incident happened in 2016
outside Dalian Atkinson's father's home
he was a former football player for
Aston Villa football club and he was 48
years old now he died after he was
tasered to the ground and given um he
was kicked um at least twice in their
head now those blows came from a
experienced police officer called
Benjamin monk he was jail for eight
years in 2021 but this tribunal today's
decision is regarding another officer
called Mary Ellen Batley Smith
um she had used her baton repeatedly on
Atkinson she initially used it three
times a tribunal heard those were lawful
times that she used it but then her
decision to hit him a further three
times after police backup had arrived
the tribe wouldn't have found was
unnecessary disproportionate and
unreasonable
um she said that she thought he was
trying to get up and that's why she had
repeatedly um delivered those blows
eyewitnesses said that he wasn't moving
and that he wasn't resistant
um PC Bentley Smith
um was last year cleared of assaulting
um Mr Atkinson but this was then
referred to the independent office for
police conduct which is now um been
looking into this and she now awaits to
find out if she'll lose her job as a
result of this
thank you